Thank You Jennifer thank you this is
really great facilities thank you to
everybody who's helped out providing
that I so this past week there was a
really funny story that was relayed
first to me by a senior faculty member
in our department and then later by my
wife I and it turns out that a senior
faculty member in my department his wife
is that her name is Ruth and she is high
school friends with Pam and Pam it turns
out is my mother-in-law's colleague okay
so I know both of these people but
they're not from the same community
right these are entirely different
worlds of my life right when it's kind
of professional the other one is
personal and these women are you know
probably six years old seven years old
maybe and it turns out that they they
know each other that's really surprising
right that there's a triangle like this
because we're not all in the same
community together earlier today I Peter
and Caroline are two friends of mine who
are here and I thought that they would
know each other and so I introduced them
to each other we're all in the same
community and it's not surprising that
at some point they would become friends
right because we're all statisticians
were all in this kind of data community
and what I'm going to talk about today
is this the importance of triangles in
detecting communities how it's really
surprising to see a triangle among nodes
that are not in the same community but
entirely expected that you do see them
in four people in the same community and
and this is what we'll call the blessing
of transitivity before we get there I'm
going to be a little bit pedantic and I
apologize for that but step back even
further back the networks and say that
historically I think the overriding
academic achievement of statisticians is
to provide a framework for making
rigorous inferences about the world and
so kind of a toy pictures that you have
the world there's some something some
questions you have about the world that
you'd like answer so you do an
experiment you somehow collect data and
you get this raw data right this raw
data is a simplification of the real
world then you do some data analysis you
further simplify this raw data he gets
summary statistics parameter estimates
visualizations right another set of step
of simplification and at the end of the
day what we want to do is in front so we
wanted to do is say something about the
world right so there's these two steps
of simplification and then we were
learning on a step up and the only way
that we can do this is with a
statistical model so George box ah I
told us that all models are wrong but
some models are useful and today what I
want to talk about is trying to improve
these models in the respect that has to
deal with triangles so then what does
this mean about networks how do we think
about networks from this paradigm I
think that the network itself is a
useful way of simplifying really complex
interactions and a complex system of
interactions if you look at for example
this network science Network it's as
simple example that's in leskovec at all
paper each each relationship here
corresponds to a one or a zero but is
representing a really much more complex
dynamic between these two researchers
and it's only represented as a one or a
zero here but at the end of the day what
we hope to do is find communities or
clusters in the network and and this
suggests that we're making some
inference to the data generating
mechanism that there's some latent
structure in this mechanism that we can
estimate and make inferences about and
so with this we can study algorithms
under under a model right this is
something that both Peters and I and
Patrick work done or talked about
earlier this morning what's a car that's
why don't you know this but yeah hey
that's what I'm saying for the subtitle
of that paper 2008 is a lack of
communities and large-scale I'm
absolutely going to attack I've
absolutely got a hot line I I can't
remember if it's if I save it for the
end or if it's earlier but definitely
yes and your name is there don't worry
I'm music quickly so in 2008 I should
say that I as you say like these these
are kind of really simple pictures of
really simple networks and at a large
scale things are much more complicated
and spilling and tagging in 2008 I think
had this really groundbreaking paper
where they suggest local clustering
algorithms from massive graphs and show
how you can have a nearly linear time
graph partitioning so it's really fast
but an empirical successes that you guys
used in your paper I believe or some
follow up version of this algorithm and
the current theory for that is that you
get perturbation bounds on graph
conductance and some running time
guarantees for the algorithm and
following that paper there were a number
of other related results on this idea of
local cluster and the idea here is that
you start off with a seed note that
there's somebody in the network that you
you are interested in maybe you want to
sell them an ad maybe it's a gene that
you know is really important for some
set of interactions and and then you
want to find a cluster that's around
that note okay and in this talk I want
to try to provide a statistical
framework for local clustering and it's
going to show that sparse and transitive
stochastic block models or plan
partition models they naturally lead to
local clustering second I want to
illustrate how this blessing of
transitivity something that has to do
with this over here is related to this
makes small clusters these local
clusters both easy easy testament
algorithmically and statistically but
and some of what I'm going to say is is
going to apply in the more general
exchangeable random graph setting that
the previous speakers have spoke about
but I think this kind of toy version of
the model is a little bit easier to talk
about I and it's the planted partition
model where k is the number of blocks
it's a number of groups s in the
population of each block so we assume
that we're conditioning on the latent
variables if you will and each block has
equal population s r is the probability
of an out of block connection the
probability that an edge crosses a
boundary of a block and P is the
probability of an in block connection
okay so just a sanity check and the
number of nodes is equal to k x s and
we're going i'm going to assume that our
probability of an out of block
connection is less than P just to make
the communities that are kind of dense
and so here's a picture of the of an
adjacency matrix from the more general
stochastic block model of course you
don't see any structure the aim is to
estimate the partition such that you
then see these blocks right and and so
what we're trying to do here in this
literature zestimate partition of the
notes and this partition I'm going to
refer to it is see this I think that
this started in the I Triple E community
somebody's feel free to correct me if
I'm wrong with that maybe with make sure
his paper in 2001 spectral partitioning
of random graphs later in 2004 and there
were kind of a trickle of papers after
that and then in the last four years has
just been an explosion of this
literature which I I we've been a part
of in some other other words along with
peter berlin patrick wolf I and and
video so this is only a small subset of
those papers where you have a stochastic
block model you sample you have some
algorithm and you want to show you can
estimate the partition
and if we think back to Peter sock and
Patricks talk I think that there are
kind of two or three and even ondrea's
talked earlier there because they're
kind of three quantities that regulate
how difficult it is to estimate Z the
partition in this literature first of
all there's edge sparsity where more
edges are better there's the size of the
smallest cluster bigger is better and
then there's the difference between this
in block and how to block probabilities
right if this is too close together then
I becomes exceedingly hard if they're
equal of and it's completely
unidentifiable and I when we're going to
zoom into the local setting and this
story it's kind of flipped around a
little bit certainly this condition
still holds but we're in a regime where
I the honor block probabilities it turns
out they have to converge to 0 and the
in block probabilities have to stay
bounded away from 0 it makes this this
part of it it's just completely
satisfied when you have sparse since I
transitive models and then these parts
kind of get flipped on their heads as
well okay so that was a little bit of
background on the this these issues now
get into the two main parts of the talk
sparse and transitive models naturally
lead to local clustering where you have
large p and vanishing are and what I
mean by local clusters are really small
block really small communities they're
not like a growing with the size of the
communities with the size of the entire
network
so we've heard a lot about sparsity
graphs worth the number of actual edges
in a network is a very small fraction of
the number of possible edges right and
so the average no degree in most
networks is maybe between 10 and 100
even in really massive cracks and
moreover this is something that we
haven't really talked about today most
empirical networks in whether it's web
or social have many more triangles than
we might otherwise expect it you get a
lot of this type this type of structure
and so we're going to want to make a
model that has both of these features
right I and and when we do that well
I'll show you what happens so here's
again transitivity if you have if you're
friends of friends then it's very likely
that you become friends right same story
over here where Peter Caroline I'm both
friends with them and so it's not
surprising that at some point that they
would meet each other and the
transitivity ratio is one way of
measuring this is proportional the
number of triangles the number of these
guys divided by the number of two stars
hi this guy yeah thanks
any other questions
so under the planted partition model
where we're assuming that r is less than
P so in block probabilities are higher
than our block probabilities if P goes
to 0 then you remove transitivity so
since transitivity is something that we
want in our network we can't let P go to
0 and this holds more generally in the
exchangeable random graph model where if
you're allowed to maximize over the
latent variables if that maximum
probability the maximum probability over
all pairs of latent variables if this
thing goes to zero you remove
transitivity in your network and so you
don't want these maximum probabilities
to go to zero this is kind of what
happens when you do the dividing by land
or something like that anyway so if P is
bounded from below then the block size
cannot grow faster than the expected
degree so these two things they're
basically just kind of like accounting
they're not a lot so they're not so
difficult but I think that they're
really informative and how we think
about the types of models that we should
consider in the asymptotic regimes that
make sense to be most applicable to real
data okay so this is just saying saying
what I said here so so this is the first
part of the busing of transitivity the
planted partition all of this model is
for parameters type of stochastic block
model with bounded expected degree so
now before we were talking about degree
growing like login or faster than log in
or polynomial in n here I we're just
going to keep it bounded okay so expect
a degree that's not grow transitivity
that implies that p the in block
probability is bounded below r is of
order 1 over N and s this is the size of
each block remember it's bounded okay so
you can't you don't get really big
blocks so think back to the previous
results that have to do with global
results global clustering results we
have a stochastic block model and you
want to estimate Z I these results
require growing degrees and growing
blocks the size of each block needs to
grow what we want to do here is study
bounded degrees and bounded blocks and
the thing that makes this possible is
that our is going to 0 LPS tank fix
third condition how close these
probabilities can come I is gets
dramatically wider asymptotically and so
here's really the important part of this
blessing is that it doesn't necessarily
make the bad edges disappear the out of
block edges can still be common order
order n but out of black triangles are
unlikely these types of triangles right
here between Ruth Pam and myself this is
the wife of a faculty member in my
department and this is my
mother-in-law's friend probability that
they're their friends is of course
really unlikely and you don't see many
triangles like this in in this in this
model in this pointed partition model on
the other hand in block triangles are
very common all right so triangles like
this where we're all statisticians you
see a lot of these things in this model
and so we look at triangles here for
computational Burkle's has been good
look at four clicks and you might get
slightly better rates here
so there's been a little bit of related
so the asymptotic setting here is it is
that you're not growing the size of each
block and that's how you make your your
network grow what you're actually doing
is you're adding blocks to your jason c
matrix asymptotically your blocks are a
fixed size and you're just adding blocks
as you go down and so there's been some
related research we have a previous
result where we kind of say this this
version of the model we need we needed
block sizes to grow passive in log n
poly log n is fine and we will use a
restricted maximum likelihood estimator
I brazilan and areas Castro we recently
have framed this as a hypothesis testing
question where you have a massive sparse
or dish runny graph there in the Poisson
limit and there's a hidden block
somewhere this growing faster than log n
it's kind of similar problem to what
Aundre is talking about and I'm not
maybe your asymptotic is setting applies
here and I should be sighting it I need
to check the citation but in this regime
the number of triangles is if it's a
powerful test statistic ok so here we
kind of assume that every note is in a
block and here there's maybe one block
and you want to test whether there is
one block that's very small
okay so here's just the pot that you
wanted Michael statistical method after
that good yeah so empirical networks
contain small communities right so I
just kind of said if you have
transitivity and sparsity under this
model then you get small communities and
kind of it's satisfying that we actually
see this and in real networks where I
leskovec lang Das Gupta Mahoney in 2008
they kind of kind of had this tour de
force where they look at all these sorts
of networks and the communities with the
smallest conductance are no larger than
100 notes even in really big graph so
you always get these nice tight clusters
and I think that transitivity what the
previous slide suggests is that
transitivity plays a key role in this
and we should use the triangles to try
and discover these local clusters this
relates to some work of Sahaj who's here
somewhere where they have more
perturbation results where they try and
break up the graph or they show that you
can break up a raft into I in the dense
regions with dense triangles going to be
an expander large size scales or does it
damage the local structure on that pot
or how does it relate to this plot do
you know so it doesn't have the
properties that you want but that was
just a toy model what I'm actually going
to suggest is actually maybe might
actually be a little bit more satisfying
um I and we'll do that in the second
part here okay five minutes transitivity
makes these small clusters easy to
estimate both statistically now
rhythmically we're going to study this
under a semi-parametric model i'll
explain that means so we started off
talking about local algorithms then we
forgot forgot local algorithms we use
stochastic block level sparsity and
transitivity to get a model with small
blocks right and in the last section are
going to combine these two threads we're
going to propose a local clustering
algorithm that looks for triangles and
then we're going to study the estimation
performance of this algorithm under a
local stochastic block level it has a
semi-parametric I that allows basically
you have a local block that
we're assuming is a block model then you
have a hairball of a network down there
and you let the hairball of the network
grow to infinity and and your block
stays fixed that's kind of the picture
that we have so I said we're going to
study local algorithms I in fact there's
a global version of our algorithm which
is easier to state I think than the
local version and this finds it for all
seed nodes with all tuning parameters
one tuning parameter so define may be
referred to as a regular i scrapped
laplacian and I so you can think of it
like the adjacency matrix at first if
you like and you compute I if this is
the adjacency matrix a times a matrix
multiplied element-wise product times a
and so what this is if it's a is the
number of triangles that contain edge i
J and so you could think of this as a
weighted graph and you run single
linkage hierarchical clustering on that
you find maximum spanning tree which for
the statisticians in the room if you can
ever phrase your problem as maximum
spanning tree do it's it's so fast this
L rule is so lightning fast thank you to
the computer scientists in the room that
make that so fast and so this thing as I
said it's called the regular eyes graph
laplacian is proposed by these authors
in 2012 immunogen bikal nina have a
similar version very similar though and
if you're interested in how to choose
tuning parameter tau we have a new paper
which suggests that the average degree
is kind of a using analytical results
which suggested that's kind of a good
thing ok so the local version of the
algorithm here's a quick go at it and
we're going to do it in a really
simplified case where we're going to
initialize with Jennifer she's our seed
node and what you do is you look at all
of Jennifers friendships are all the
friendships that cross the edge boundary
and you say is this edge in a triangle
so this one is not in a triangle it's
when the 80 is right and so and all of
these other ones are in triangles so in
the next step you add any edge that it's
in this triangle so you get this block
and it right again where you look at all
of the edges coming from these people
and you stop when you have no edges that
leave the cluster that are in a triangle
okay that's kind of the simple version
of the
algorithm you can make the number of
necessary triangles kind of a tuning
parameter and with the graph laplacian
you make it wait them wait the degrees
of the nodes which is kind of a nice
thing okay so now we want to study the
performance of this algorithm under
statistical model and since the local
version of this album it only searches
locally right research from Jennifer and
then we just go out we only need a local
model that is we only assume something
stochastic around Jennifer and then
there's the people in her community that
is still sarcastic but then everything
else in the network we might not need to
assume so much right so there's three
pieces of the network there's the seed
node and its local block and then
there's the rest of the network which is
just some giant hairball and we're not
going to make any parametric assumptions
no degree distribution no maximum degree
assumptions this can be whatever you
want as long as it's sparse and
independent of the relationships that go
between the local block and the hairball
okay so this is as a fair to call this a
semi-parametric maybe not so satisfying
maybe okay the point is that we don't
need to assume that this is say Arish
runny or anything like that the price
you pay of course is that you start off
with a node that's in the block right
that there's a node that you're
particularly interested in
alright so then there's two versions of
this model the first one is not degree
corrected the second one is I and you
can use the adjacency matrix when it's
not degree corrected but you need to use
at the fashion when it is degree
corrected and this version works a whole
lot better in practice just use the
graphical portion the regular I scraps
of fashion so if the if you have the
correct seating and the ambient graph
this is hairball of network is sparse
then the local algorithm returns the
cluster with high probability but it
doesn't require growing degrees right
before you needed growing degrees we
don't need that Peck that's kind of a
bad thing and you don't need growing s
right so we're in the fixed block case
that we want to be in we don't require a
specific model on this hairball of a
network most of what's going on and I we
don't require a bounded degree in this
hairball sorry to say that so many times
I think that that's really important and
what happens here is so this term is the
probability that your your greedy
algorithm is going to slip outside your
block that you're somehow going to
include some note that's that's in the
hairball ok in this term it goes to zero
and then this term explains is just the
probability that you get everybody in
your cluster alright that you get
everybody in the block this term does
not go to 0 or 1 hope you stay there
they're just bad things that can happen
because block is not growing right there
could be no edges in there and that
probability does not converge to 0 so
this can't go to go to one and be
perfectly consistent but the slipping
outside does does all the way
as farce you don't have found a degree
the average degree is constant or
doesn't grow with it or it can grow with
that book it's it's a tuning from its
lambda and it appears right there this
little guys there s is the size of the
the block excuse me um so we don't
assume that the size of the local
cluster grows s it's fixed you could
make it grow and then this would this
would go 21 questions so here's with a
graph of passion in the degree corrected
version in the degree corrected version
the probability of crossing the boundary
from your local block to the hairball is
proportional to a nodes degree in the
hairball so really high degree nodes and
the hairball are more likely to attract
edges yeah so this is just a regular
regular eyes graph laplacian from here
they also help infuse life yes exactly
okay so we have not compared this to any
other algorithms but it does give some
reasonable results on not huge networks
but fairly large networks and you can do
this I did this on my mac air really
small computer in our it's really fast
to do the global version and so these
next plots I want to show the induced
sub graph of some of these local
clusters when I first made this plateaus
really kind of shocked like I didn't
know what to expect but I'm just looking
at hairballs of networks that you can't
really understand what's going on and
the point here when you plot these
things locally right so these to be sure
that these nodes come from a 70,000 node
network I'm only plotting a very small
part of it we can actually kind of tell
a story about what's going on and so
getting to Jennifer's point about
validation yes please end this algorithm
from disease are you ran in from Iran
the global version where you run it on
all seed nodes with all tuning
parameters and then I just kind of took
some of the nice ones you can if you if
this was a scientific application and
you're really interested in this cluster
for some particular reason you can
actually plot it and and the
statisticians these visualizations in
for example regression are really big
part of validation right that's how we
kind of validate our linear model
assumptions is by visualization and
we're starting to get to a regime where
you can actually plot these things and
understand them because we're looking at
local clustering because we're looking
at small communities here's kind of a
weird example right maybe notes nine and
three your kind of weird in this we
could look at them further if you call
it go to that by a degree in the
photograph does the local procedure you
running bias yourself for a high degree
nodes like a diffusion what are the key
to itself locally so it'd be much
you don't device so that's why you we
have to do the regular eyes graph
laplacian the graph laplacian kind of
down wait sit there might still be some
bias in the end but that's why you
really need that otherwise it just
everything goes haywire okay so here's a
less transmit for I ok times up its own
local clustering is justified for
several reasons I and and I think that
one of the really big parts of local
clustering is that it's answering a new
type of question we're not interested in
making a partition of our entire huge
billion node network right you're
interested in 11 page you're interested
in one user and in that really local
question really speaks to that and
there's empirical evidence for these
small communities computation
visualization interpretation Diagnostics
they all improve I ok so I'm finally the
blessing of transitivity this idea that
your triangles in clusters but are very
unlikely outside of clusters allows for
these fast algorithms and and
semi-parametric results in networks